I don't know what to think about these
rebooted Star Trek films my name is
James Tiberius Kirk you see the de
ecology of Trek films had appeared
between 1979 and 2002 were all films
about characters that mainly existed in
a TV show universe the premise II of the
TV version was never in doubt in fact
the movies got better when they lowered
the budgets and the writing became more
TV like you said you would kill me I
lied but the latest JJ Abrams version
turns the familiar and beloved cast of
characters into typical blockbuster
action heroes there are four of us and
one of you forget some more guys and
it'll be an even fight characters are
established at warp five speed enlist in
Starfleet inland hello ladies and their
character arts are secondary to the
battle scenes Kirk and Sulu fighting on
a sky platform and falling hundreds of
miles to the planet's surface come on
I prefer clumsy old school fight scenes
with double fist punches that were
clearly choreographed by the actors
themselves when star trek into darkness
comes out I will register my displeasure
the same way I did in 2009 with my
wallet I will only see star trek into
darkness once during its theatrical run
at full price I mean I'll go see it
again in a matinee but I won't pay full
price more than once
you dare disagree with me show your
courage in the comments and subscribe to
the wire channel if you haven't already
you